the Joe Rogan experience of course
someone just on my on my Instagram just
posted a picture of a tattoo a beautiful
tattoo of the werewolf oh yeah so many
people have them well one guy did a
cover-up tattoo that was incredible the
werewolf bidet it's funny I mean have
them werewolf I have hairy on people
I've got the Grange yeah and some of the
stuff Harry and the Hendersons yeah yeah
that's another one oh and that's one of
the films I think still I mean when
people ask me what my favorite one is I
say Harry because I I can look at that
film today I think it holds up perfectly
what fine
the only thing I think I would change is
I would make his teeth a little more
translucent yeah but that was a
challenging movie because he had to
communicate and just by his visual
expressions right and and carry the
movie you know and I think he did and I
think it works quite well was there is
there a movie that stands out as being
the most frustrating like the end result
probably you know I mean they're all
frustrating to a degree you know what I
don't know if there's one particular one
I mean I did and I don't consider this
my film I was approached by Bob
Weinstein to do a werewolf movie called
cursed that West Craig was going to
direct and I basically turned it down
and there wasn't a lot of time and Bob
used my own words against me apparently
onna on a DVD of American worldly said
I'd love to have the opportunity to do a
transformation again and do it knowing
what I know now on with the crew that I
have now Brian Nicholas I'm giving you
that you said that you know so I said to
him the only way I would do this is if
you don't have an opinion and Wes
doesn't have an opinion you just let me
make what I think is best for this film
it's the only way I can make it cool in
the time that you have I can't play that
change this change that game you know
absolutely you know the horse that's not
the case and they say that and they say
yeah you know it's like change this
change that change the stage that and it
was just like you know and you almost
have to have a clause in the contract if
they do [ __ ] with you at all you could
just leave and get paid
I've done that you know in in one one
kind of attack but yeah it turned out
the they started the film before they
really had a script and it was oh yeah
it happens all the time and they it was
just a mess and this haven't heard of it
first you know what's good you didn't
hear but I'm surprised I'm even
mentioning it because it did they shut
the film down and I went okay I said but
we were we were doing some really cool
transformation stuff in it wasn't quite
done and I said listen if you ever think
the film's gonna pick up again if you
can keep a number of my people on for
another month we can have this
transformation stuff or put it in a box
we'll be ready to go so if they starting
again because necessarily get the same
people you know right you know I know
and just put everything in a box you
know kept it to us we're you know if we
start up again you know we'll figure it
out they started up again I didn't do it
I was on something else someone else
took over then they changed everything
that I made they didn't use a lot of
what I made but the film has a single
card opening credits as Rick Baker on it
and I I spoke with the Weinstein ago I
don't want credit for this film it's not
my film this isn't my work anymore but
it would help them to have you on it
yeah yeah so I mean I found that
frustrating you know but you know again
I have no right to complain about this
stuff they don't do a lot of monster
movies anymore and the number of
werewolf movies you can kind of count
them on one hand right I mean the owl is
extremely stretchy here we have the
howling of course you have American
Werewolf you have the earlier films but
this it's you know and then you have
those I don't consider them werewolf
movies those what are the ones with the
lady there underworld beckons do
underworld yeah yeah those are kind of
but but they're fun to watch Kate
Beckinsale in it they take suit it's
pretty [ __ ] hot yeah but they're just
kind of whack the movies are kind of why
the vampires are whack it's like I don't
buy any what you're selling I don't
think he's a real vampires I'm not
scared I don't think that's a werewolf
get the [ __ ] out of here yeah one more
old school yeah horror movie guy you
know I'm not a big slasher movie guy you
know I mean now again
like I mean I can't I can't watch those
fights that your nose in UFC fights oh
really
I have a one of my crew eddying shout
out to add a great guy yeah Eddie was
the priest uh D with all the Gracie's
okay and he was saying hey you gotta
watch this Rick and I mean these guys
hitting each other in the face with
elbow and III know it's not for me you
know what and people will send me
because they think I like this stuff
pictures oh look fell down cut my head
you know pass out when I cut myself you
know really yeah yeah yeah
I mean fake gore is one thing you know
but I I think it's bad that you know a
movie you know when you know Halloween
and and Friday the 13th and it just
became what's the most graphic way we
can kill a teenager right and people
become when you see you know a guy with
a you know get shoved in a knife shoved
in design that people is like cheer all
right that seems wrong to me you know
yeah the desensitization you know you
should be repulsed by this stuff right
and I mean I you know it's I don't know
but it's so fun I mean people would
think it's funny and kind of ironic
coming from someone like you who's made
these insane monster films like American
Werewolf in London we're just ripping
guys heads off Piccadilly sorry it's
monster gory you know and it's something
like you know if it's a zombie killing
you're killing zombie that's okay you
know that that's not real you know right
but just killing a person it another
person killing a person in a graphic way
Brian I'm not fond of you know so I
don't like you know I mean I I like you
I call them monster movies more than
Bryce you don't need to yeah and you
know I mean that Charles Laughton
quasimodo I mean it's brilliant
mmm-hmm yes it's a brilliant makeup yeah
1939 right and you know it's a perfect
makeup on a perfect actor you know
Charles LA was great in that movie and
you feel for him you know you feel
further Frankenstein's monster you know
and those those movies just don't
they're so few and far between today
like I see a real Frankenstein type
movie
[Applause]